les éleveurs ne tue pas les animaux pour
le plaisir y tuent les animaux pas tous
d'ailleurs et pas forcément enfin je
veux dire c'est c'est une des
possibilités de la sortie du travail des
animaux c'est pas la seule à garder les
animaux qu'il va qui n'iront jamais à
l'abattoir
mais en même temps cette mort là elle
prend sens justement parce que on vit on
travaille avec les animaux parce que bon
je le dis brillamment parce que c'est ça
sera un peu long mais c'est l'un des
systèmes d'élevage c'est un système
finit donc c'est un endroit où on fait
naître des animaux et comme il ya des
ressources de manière fini la cia design
qui naissent fauqué des animaux qui
partent ça c'est commencer le béaba de
l'histoire et d'autre part l'autre b à
ba c'est que on est des êtres niveau
look on mange de la viande mais pas
seulement la viande c'est pas le
problème d'ailleurs le derrière le
délire derrière le podium où qui a aussi
de la viande d'ailleurs le petit fromage
de chèvre ya aussi de la mort des
animaux
donc il faut prendre les choses de
manière globale et
et se dire que cette cette morale un
sens dans le cadre du travail avec les
animaux et cela depuis dix mille ans et
parvient pas de l'inventer s'affaiblit
milan on vit qu'on travaillait que les
animaux qu'a vécu un produit des
aliments et qu' une partie des animaux
un agent un autre est abattu pour nous
alimenter pour nous rien et c'est un
problème est pas là le problème
et comme on élève les animaux est ce que
les élèves d'ailleurs où est-ce qu'on
est produit comme des choses est
derrière est ce qu'on leur donne une
mort digne c'est à dire un spectacle
pour eux et pour nous ou est ce qu'en
ont les transforme comme des choses
comme c'est le cas dans les systèmes
industriels c'est ça l'enjeu maintenant
la mort des animaux
elle a un sens pour les éleveurs
d'ailleurs quand on est éleveur
évidemment on fait rentrer cette mort
des animaux dans le sens général nous
notre travail
[Musique]